Ed: Hello, everyone.
Good evening.
I'd like to welcome
you to the - (laughter)
The MIT Club of California.
Tonight, we have an excellent,
distinguished speaker,
but before we introduce
him, I hope you have enjoyed
the sandwiches and cookies.
We learned to make those ourselves
by watching one of
Sal's videos. (laughter)
Just kidding, they're
from Subway. (laughter)
Let me read a bio for Sal.
Sal is a social entrepreneur who
has become an internet sensation
and inspiration for his fun
and highly effective
educational videos on YouTube.
Every month, more than 100,000 students,
both young and old, across the globe,
use his over 1,300 free videos
to learn about arithmetics,
finance, chemistry,
(unintelligible) calculus.
He founded the Khan Academy,
which was recently covered
on CNN, PBS News, NPR, San Francisco
Chronicle, and NBC Nightline.
His mission is nothing
short of creating a free
and world class virtual school
for anyone in the world.
He will speak about his
experience starting the academy
and massively transformational
changes in learning and teaching.
(unintelligible) in the
next five to ten years.
Sal graduated from MIT in 1998
with computer science and math degrees
and received his MBA from
Harvard Business School.
He left his day job as a
hedge fund analyst in 2009
to dedicated full time to
his non-profit academy.
We're delighted and honored to have
this distinguished speaker tonight,
an emerging giant in the
online education space,
a world-class educator,
a dynamic communicator,
and a selfless good-doer,
Salman Khan. (applause)
Sal: Can you all hear me?
I'd prefer to just be
closer to you all, than ...
Can you hear me in the back?
Okay, cool.
Just like Ed said, I'm Sal,
the founder and faculty
of the Khan Academy. (laughter)
This is -
I really want to make this -
I think this will be a fun conversation.
I don't want this to be me at the
PowerPoint for the whole hour.
I really want you all to
interrupt me or raise your hand,
ask me questions, and we can
take this wherever we want to go,
because there's really a couple of
different conversations we can have
and maybe we can have them all.
How many of you all have
watched a Khan Academy video?
Okay, that's a pretty good cover.
Just so you know what it is, and actually,
maybe to get a sense, of the growth.
Ed said 100,000 and when he
first asked me it was 100,000,
now it's 200,000 unique students a
month and it's only been two months.
It is the fastest growing
open course effort.
Now, it's actually passed up -
I'm not - Well, I'm a little competitive.
It passed up MIT recently,
in terms of (laughter)
being the most used.
It's getting about 60 or
70,000 video views a day.
It has closed to 16
million views on YouTube.
One of the things we can
talk about is maybe why.
It might be something about the
content, how it's delivered and whatnot.
We can talk about all of that.
This is the site, just for those
of you all who have never seen it.
We can also debate my
user interface skills
for just putting all 1,400
links (laughter) on one page.
Those are the videos and if
you click on a random video,
if you want a review of
(unintelligible) you can click there.
We can let it load up or whatever.
That's the Khan Academy.
What I want to do - (unintelligible)
Is there sound?
The sound isn't any different than
what you're hearing right now.
(laughter) You see this and you
hear my voice and you don't see me.
This'll give you a flavor
for the form factor.
That could be a conversation we could have
about why this is an interesting
form factor and why I did it
and all of that type of thing.
What I'm going to focus on,
because I think most people
are familiar with the video library.
It has this reach, it's gotten popular,
it's growing 10 or 15%
a month at this point.
I want to talk about the bigger vision.
Ed has talked about this idea of
starting a virtual school for the world
and obviously, videos are a start.
They're the lecture part of a school,
but a real school's got to
be more than just video.
You have to have some
interaction with other people,
you have to have practice,
you have to have assessment,
you have to have data
and all of these things.
That's what I want to talk about
and I'm generally open to ideas,
because this is a work in progress.
Some of it is starting to be built.
Hopefully over the next few months
it'll be built in a much bigger way.
Some volunteers have come out
of the woodwork very recently
to supercharge some of these efforts.
It's exciting times.
Let me get the presentation up.
A good number of you all saw the videos.
How many of you all saw the
web application on the site?
Okay, that's a much
lower penetration rate.
Just so you all know a
little bit of the history,
and I'm happy to go into
this as much as you want,
but I started doing
this remotely tutoring,
because I was in Boston, my
cousins were in New Orleans,
and she was having trouble
with units and I said,
"Hey, after your school and my
work let's get together virtually.
"We'll use Yahoo Doodle,
it'll be a shared notepad
"that we can each see what
each other is writing."
I got her a little Wacom pen
tablet, I had one for myself.
We'd just do conference calls
and that's how I started.
Then she started doing really well,
then I started tutoring her
brothers, other cousins.
Then a couple of things happened
and I usually go straight to the videos,
because that's what it's known for,
but being a computer science geek,
I didn't even think of
doing the videos at first.
I said, "Hey, you know what,
I'm going to write soft -
I would give them these little lectures
and I would just point them
to random websites, like,
"Hey, there's a cool applet
on that website over there.
"Why don't you try it out and tell
me tomorrow whether you understood,
"whether you're able to
do those exercises, or use
that website over there,"
I just got really frustrated, this
piecemeal website here, website there,
so I said, "I'm going to
write a couple of javascript,
"little things that'll
generate problems for them."
It's not just ten problems and it
may come up with some random numbers
and give them as many
problems as they need.
I made a bunch of these modules.
I'll show you what the modules look like.
This is like a multiplying decimals module
and we can go into as much
depth on these as you want.
I started making these little
javascript modules for them
and it was starting really where
she was, at units and basic algebra
and adding and subtracting
negative numbers,
and basic linear
equations and then I said,
"Gee, you know, I don't trust -
I'd say, "Hey, Nadia,
did you do the problems?
"How many did you do?"
and she's like, "Oh yeah, I did
them (unintelligible) (laughter)
I was like, "I'm going to put
a database behind this thing."
I put a database behind
it so I could keep track
of when she did the problem,
how long was it taking her,
how many times was she doing,
how frequently was she getting
one right or one wrong.
Then I started making them up.
On that first slide right there,
each of these circles is a module,
and literally, the first module -
This was a very organic process.
It was really just me working
with my cousins and iterating,
saying it would be nice to have the data.
Then, I started making
modules here one off
and I would at first
just point them to it.
Then after a while, I was like,
there's some kind of dependency here,
because Nadia got that, but
she needs help with that,
so to fill in that gap,
let me make another module.
Then, after a while, I got tired
of having to assign the modules,
so I said, "Well, it should
automatically assign the modules,
"because once she gets
ten in a row in this,
"she's ready for this, this, and this."
So, I created this internal
dependency in the little app
to do this and I said, "Well,
this is kind of a neat graph."
This is what I was using just
to keep track of the modules,
I should just expose this to the students,
so they know what's going on.
This is the app and this started
well before I made the first video,
but it's kind of like the
secret of the Khan Academy,
so you're getting a little tidbit.
But I think it's also the
future on a lot of levels.
So this right here, this is
literally level one addition,
so it's literally 1+1.
If you go to the website,
there is literally a video
on 1+1 and at first, it's almost
a joke that I made the video
on adding 1+1, but the
whole idea behind it,
besides being cute, is
to give people the notion
that no matter how basic your
skills, you can go to this site
and you will find something
that fits your need
and the idea that you can, when
you see 1+1 on the same page
as vector calculus, you're like,
"Gee, I just have to step through that
thing and I can get to vector calculus.
"There's not some mysterious - (laughter)
"And it's the same dude who's going
to take me through the - (laughter)
"My Kindergarten teacher is
teaching me vector calculus."
(laughter) You get ten in a row and -
Once this was made, then
it started to make -
This became what a lot of
people in education talk about,
differentiated learning,
with data and all of that,
but it made me pause and say,
"This is working for my cousins,"
but there was actually
one piece that was missing
and that was the -
I still had to do -
When I first started it, I thought -
It randomly generated these problems
and picked random numbers here
and then when you clicked hint,
it would show you the exact
steps for that problem.
I was like, "Oh, that's all you
need to learn how to do a problem.
"You just need the exact
steps for that exact problem.
"This'll work for my cousins."
But it didn't.
It would help them if they kind of
knew how to multiply decimals already,
but it didn't get them over that hurdle.
I still had to do that one-on-one
session with them remotely.
That became hard to scale.
Literally, another buddy
from MIT, we were at dinner
and he's like, "Why don't
you make YouTube videos?
"The thing that you do with your cousins,
"why don't you just
record that on YouTube?"
I was completely dismissive of the idea.
I was like, "Oh, that's so
silly, I have this software.
"It generates problems
dynamically, (laughter)
"it's got hints, what's a
YouTube video going to do?"
He's like, "Yeah, you're right,
it's probably a stupid idea."
(laughter) I went home and I was like,
"Well, maybe there's something to it."
Literally, when I kept recording
videos with my cousins,
I would do the tenth lecture on
negative numbers with a new cousin,
I was like, "Yeah, maybe a
YouTube video will make sense."
I made the first YouTube video
on greatest common divisor
and this and that and then -
I've said this in talks
before, the immediate feedback
I got from my cousins was that,
"You are better on YouTube
than you are live." (laughter)
The point, I think, that he
was trying to communicate is
it had none of the pressure of
a traditional tutoring session.
"Did you get this?" and
you're staring at the person.
They're like, "Yeah,
maybe I did," (laughter)
and they're giving you bad information,
because they didn't get it.
They feel bad pausing or repeating me,
but they can do it all they
want with a YouTube video,
or they can go to Wikipedia, or they
might be afraid of even admitting
that they don't know how to
borrow or regroup or whatever,
but now they can actually review
it in these one off videos.
Then other people started
watching it, as well, and said,
"Hey, there's something
there," and on top of that,
I incorporated with this,
because that was the whole point
in the first place, to have if you've
never seen this concept before,
you at least have this
outlet, these YouTube videos
that you could somehow access, but
before I go into the depths of this,
I want to -
Once this was built, then I had
this, "This seems to be working,
"but let's compare it to what goes
on right now in the school system."
If you think, the whole conversation
about education right now,
it's all about the student-teacher ratios,
how can we make the
inner city, poor schools
look a lot like the fancy, rich
schools, give people computers,
but no one is fundamentally
questioning the model.
If you really think
about the model itself,
I don't want to taint
your opinion before -
It's bizarre.
You have this situation,
you go to the classroom
and you're all in a room together -
We'll talk about what you could do
if you're all in a room together,
but there's no interaction.
It's just this broadcast
lecture, especially once you get
to the university level, but even
in the classroom in middle school.
There might be a little
one question here or there,
but fundamentally, it's a
broadcast lecture to the room.
The teacher is pretty much
guaranteed to lose half the students,
or bore half the students,
and at some point,
they're going to switch the whole time.
You do that, then the student has
to go home, do their homework.
They do it in a complete vacuum.
They have a textbook, every other problem
there's a solution in
the back, you don't know
why you got it right or wrong, anything.
You don't have anyone to help you.
If you're lucky you might get a tutor
or a parent might be able to help you.
Then you go to the class the next day
and there might be some
type of review of homework
or something, but really no real feedback
and the cycle repeats itself.
You get another lecture,
then you go back home,
you do homework in a
vacuum, and this whole time
you don't know what you're doing at all.
The teacher has no data, nothing.
That occurs for a couple of days
and then, bam, you have an assessment.
The assessment, some students
get 50%, 80%, 70%, 90%.
The good students get 95%, next concept.
Even if you fail an
exam, the class moves on.
You don't know half of the
subject, half of the material
in that previous concept and
the class is going to move on.
You might say that failing student's bad
and the A students are all right,
but they still didn't
know 5% of the concept.
Maybe it was a careless mistake,
but maybe they didn't know
what happens when you take
something to the zeroth power.
Maybe they didn't know exactly
what a fractional exponent was,
that one problem on the exam
with the fractional exponent.
That A student, the one who's
getting the positive label,
when they go to calculus
and they see that,
what are they going to do?
They're not going to get 95%,
they're going to get 90%,
because they're going to miss
that and another concept.
That's not even to mention about the 50%.
You have this bizarre -
The first time you get
assessment is when it's time
to move to the next concept.
In no way is it actionable.
If you really think about the process,
it's just this huge filtering mechanism.
It's just this process
where every step of the way
we're just knocking
more and more people off
and the lucky people in this
room, we were the people
who happened to be lucky
enough that we were assessed
and filtered at the right
place at the right time
and that led to us feeling really
smart and going on. (laughter)
That's the way it works.
It makes you really question -
We're all lucky. (laughter)
That's the big takeaway.
What's happening here, what
I think is happening here,
is that whole cycle, it's
all happening instantaneously
with every interaction.
The instruction, if you've never seen
multiplying decimals before in
your life, you click "watch video",
it pumps in from YouTube,
and you can imagine
there's one or two videos right now,
but you eventually have ten videos,
you're tracking whether the
person watched the video,
you can eventually track
whether they paused or repeated,
where they watched, and I'll
talk more about that later on,
how you can perfect the content.
They get the instruction there,
then they can do the practice,
so you're giving them practice
and you get immediate feedback.
Did I get it right or wrong?
If you don't know how to do it, you
get the exact steps for that problem
and then you're also getting assessment,
because every time you do a problem,
it's tracking everything about that.
When you did it, how long it took you,
how many times did you click "hint",
and then the paradigm here, and I
literally did this just on a whim,
I was just like, "How do I know if
someone really knows something?"
It's not 90%, or it's not 95%, just keep
doing it until you get ten in a row.
Ten in a row should be the paradigm,
because then that will enforce
a certain level of discipline.
People say, "Oh isn't that -
No, when you take the SAT, you can't make
those little careless mistakes.
You should enforce a
certain level of precision.
I just threw out ten in a row.
It doesn't have to be ten in a
row, it could be five in a row,
or whatever, depending on the concept,
but if you think about what's
happening when you enforce it
is you don't allow that
95% student to move on
while not knowing that 5% and then
only get lost in the next topic.
That's the general idea.
This right here is the -
This is just another example of a module.
This is slope of a line.
If you don't know how to do, just do
"hint" and it draws things for you.
It's just another indication of -
All of this is live.
You can go right now to
KhanExercises.appspot.com
and you can try out all of
this stuff and I encourage you
if you have friends or family members.
There was even a guy at the
hedge fund I worked with
who was going to take the GMAT
and he was summa cum laude
from Yale and he's like,
"What should I use for math?"
"You should use this."
He was like, "Hey, but this
is starting me at 1+1."
I said, "Just do it."
Two weeks later, he was like,
"That was good." (laughter)
It's amazing how long many people
haven't multiplied decimals. (laughter)
That's the self-paced
student view of the world.
I still haven't given you
the whole virtual school.
Right now we're talking about videos
and then we've kind of automated
the self-directed learning
and learning at your own
pace and getting assessed,
but then you have to think about
how can you incorporate that
with the human experience.
You're coming into a room
together to essentially learn
how can you use this technology
to hyper charge that?
Actually, before I even talk about this,
there's actually a very simple
flipping of the classroom
that I think should occur tomorrow.
You don't need any of this software,
because the videos already exist
and some teachers - It wasn't my idea -
A teacher in London said that he is now -
If you think, it's actually a no-brainer.
I don't understand why this
doesn't happen worldwide tomorrow.
He is now assigning the
lectures for homework
and he's having the students
do homework in the classroom.
There's no other technology necessary.
Think about what happens there.
Right now, we all gather at
seven in the morning in 10250
and we're all with our
peers and (unintelligible)
We have to sit passively and
just get this broadcast lecture
and then we go off on our own
and we do these problem sets in a vacuum.
If you flip the model and
the lecture, as we said,
is one size fits all, I
might be lost or bored,
I might have gaps from the last
lecture that I didn't understand,
but I still have to
get this exact lecture.
You flip the model, you get
on-demand video at home,
when you're ready for
it, when you're awake.
I got a letter from a student
about they did actually have
a good calculus teacher, but
he had two rows in front of him
this really cute girl and every
day he's just trying to figure out
how he can ask her out and he missed
two months of calculus. (laughter)
This was his only -
(laughter)
I say that's a story of another
person, but - (laughter)
We all had similar stories. (laughter)
We go home and we do these
problem sets in a complete vacuum.
We have no one to help
us, but if you flip it,
you can watch things at your
own pace, fill in your gaps,
do whatever you need and then
when you're in the classroom,
you have 30 or 40 or 400
of your peers to help you
and you have the professor
who can walk around
and in real time, see
how people are doing,
two weeks before the
assessment, two weeks before
everyone gets that label
placed on their head
that they're a B student.
If you really think about it,
honestly, and I'm not this touchy -
These people who are
anti-grades and that's like,
oh, that's touchy feely.
I'm anti-grades because
I think it's ridiculous.
It's not about -
It's because if you're a
B student, you shouldn't -
Everyone should be forced
to be an A student.
It's on that concept.
It's silly, you'll meet many, many people,
and I think this room is an exception,
but you'll meet many, many people who went
through algebra, algebra
two, geometry, pre-calculus,
trigonometry, calculus, and
when they see an algebra problem
in front of their face, they don't see it.
They have never had mastery
of anything in between
and this whole exercise of
going from one hoop to the next
and being an A- student the whole way,
it's just an exercise in
filtering, it's not an exercise
in actually making people
have tangible skills
that they can do
something productive with.
What I just described, flipping the model,
that's if you have no technology,
but if you have the technology,
what you can do is teach -
There's a bunch of student
names here that you can't see,
I've blanked them out, but this is
a report that a teacher could have
and this is actually a real report,
this isn't a Photoshop version.
This was at a summer camp where they used
what I showed you in
the last couple slides
as their math curriculum,
where every student was able
to work at their own pace and
the teacher walks in every day.
Each column here is one of those modules
that we saw on that first
slide, one of those concepts.
Each row here is a student.
Green means the student already
got ten in a row on that concept.
They did it, they're cool.
Purple means that they're
working on it right now,
that that's their frontier
of learning at the moment.
Everything seems to be going okay.
Red means that students done 50 problems.
Sometimes you can think of the heuristic.
That student's done 50 problems,
95% of students who have done 50 problems
in that module usually move on.
This student has not.
Some type of intervention should occur,
some type of human intervention.
A teacher could look at this and
either they could eyeball it.
They could say, "Hey,
look, everyone's doing fine
"but these two kids need
help in level two division.
"Let everyone else work at their own pace,
" let me just take
these two students aside
"and do a very intimate,
focused intervention
"on just those two students."
Even better, you can pair
these two students up
with these two students initially
and see if that gets them over the hurdle.
You can actually capture the
data before and after that.
I'm not there yet, but if the software
is actually scheduling the interactions,
you can actually see
what happens before those
and start to rank teachers and
students and all of that type of thing.
Slowly work up to the
level of the teacher.
What I think should happen and
hope that this catalyzes it
is we go back to a one-room schoolhouse.
We go back to room full of
people, from Kindergartners
all the way to anybody.
Senior citizens who want
to come back and learn
and they're all working at their own pace
and if you have trouble with a
concept, even if you don't know,
this will know if you having
trouble with a concept.
It will pair you with somebody else
and it'll know about that interaction,
it'll know how good of an
instructor that person was
before and after, you'll
rate them, whatever else.
Then, you can keep escalating
up and up the ladder
until eventually you can
get by the paid teacher.
You can actually have a reality where -
Obviously there's a huge aspect
of actually teaching people for retention.
This isn't just a way to
get economics and scale.
This whole mechanism, I'm a ninth grader
and I'm teaching a sixth
grader negative numbers.
That, by itself, is a
hugely powerful tool.
I'm learning things better
than I ever learned before
just doing these videos.
You can imagine if you're -
And this whole level of maturity.
I think, actually, if
you hang out with people
older and younger than yourself,
you actually act more mature
for a whole set of reasons.
Then, all of a sudden, you have a
model, where everyone is learning,
the classroom is actually
an interactive experience,
it's no longer a passive
experience, everyone is operating
exactly at the level that they need to,
and it actually scales.
You can actually make it economic.
You could actually have -
Everyone's obsessed with
student-teacher ratios,
but student-teacher ratios assume a model
that if there's one of me and ten of you,
then we can have a conversation.
If there's one of me and 20 of you,
we're going to have
less of a conversation.
If there's one of me and 100 of you,
we're not going to have a conversation.
That's true, to some degree, but here,
everyone works at their own pace.
Even if there's 100
students and one paid tutor,
because you have this
interaction, I'm willing to bet
that you're going to
have a better interaction
with that one paid teacher who
can now be paid 100 grand a year,
instead of what teachers get paid.
You're going to have a better
interaction in this world
with a 100:1 student-teacher
ratio, than you'd probably get
in even the fanciest private
schools that there are right now.
This right here, this is
literally the summer program
had asked about this and
I was curious myself.
This was literally me just
doing sequel queries in the data
every night from the summer camp.
It's not like a rigorous study,
but to me, it speaks to the power
of every student working at their own pace
and throws into question, the
traditional notions of assessment,
which we, I think, sense are
(unintelligible) to begin with.
What this chart is doing,
this axis right here
is the days in the summer camp.
It was a six-week program
and this is just a count
of the modules completed.
This black line right here, that's
the class mean, the class average.
On day seven in this class
of 30 or so students,
the average student has
completed 23 modules.
That's what that tells us.
You can actually even see
that they all started at 1+1.
It was actually an interesting idea,
because we started
another group not at 1+1
and some subset of the
students always got stuck.
They just never moved on, even
though we started them at fifth grade
and they were seventh graders,
some subset always got stuck.
We saw when we started everyone
at 1+1, no one got stuck,
which tells you that there
are some smart people
who have some gaps and it
never gets addressed otherwise.
You can have the best
algebra teacher on the planet
and you can have an innately
very intelligent kid,
but if he or she just is a little
foggy on multiplying decimals,
there's no hope, they're just
going to talk past each other
and it's just going to be a
very frustrating experience.
When we started everyone at
1+1, and you see it here.
It's a very steep curve,
this is the review.
This was the kids just getting ten
in row, ten in row, ten in a row.
Then it starts to level out a bit.
This is, you can see
the learning happening.
The interesting thing, at least to me,
the interesting thing about
this is the green lines
are standard deviation
above and below that mean.
You can plot all the students here,
but this student in particular,
on day five, if you did a
pre-assessment for the class,
if you did an assessment right
here, he only completed 12 modules.
More than one standard
deviation below the mean.
If you were in the traditional,
if you were tracking students,
you'd say, "Oh, she's a remedial student,
"she's going to hold the class back,
"or we have to hold the rest
of the class back for her.
"She doesn't belong in here," all that
and you would put a big
label on her forehead.
"You're never going to be an
engineer," and all of these things
and actually it does happen
around sixth or seventh grade.
That is when these labels, these
careers get ruled out for students.
Because she was able to spend a little -
I was curious, I was like,
"What happened to her?"
and I could go into the data and I
could see exactly what she was doing.
She was spending more
time than everyone else
on adding and subtracting
negative numbers.
Just to understand this
chart right here, each bar,
this is the first problem she did.
Red is wrong, blue is right, and
the height is how long it took her.
This is just from the
data of the interaction.
You can see she got a
couple of questions wrong,
then she maybe guessed one right,
then you have this big long time
she actually watched the video here.
I looked at the video log.
She watched the video here, then
she got a couple more right,
but then she still got a few wrong.
Once again, in a traditional classroom,
she would have been said, "Oh, at
this point you are an A student.
"You got nine of ten right,
or you got 19/20 right
"and you're an A student,"
and force her to keep going.
A couple more right, one wrong,
then finally she got ten in a row.
You can actually see that
she also got faster on it.
There's a whole other element of speed,
which does matter on
some standardized tests.
Once she got through
that, once she was able
to just remediate herself
and really build a strong
foundation, she just raced ahead.
This was just in six weeks.
She went from being the second
to worst student in the class,
if you want to measure that way,
to the second to third best.
All the students are on the chart here.
In just six weeks.
It makes you question, if
you did an assessment here,
and I show that because
she literally raced
through level three linear
equations, which is like 2x+7=-3x-4
and she just thought it was intuitive
after doing maybe level two.
She just raced.
If you saw that student,
you'd say, "Oh, she's gifted."
(laughter) It makes you really question.
We were just the lucky kids that
got assessed at the right time
and got all positive feedback and
we were assessed at that point,
but there's probably a lot of
people who might've been able
to eat our lunch eventually,
who got kicked off.
This, I show this, this
is data from YouTube.
I think everything I talked about before
is how do you make sure
a student learns properly
and how do you make sure that
their foundation is built
and how do you use that data to optimize
the actual physical
interactions, but I show this
to show that there's another dimension
of perfecting the actual content.
This is data that YouTube gives me.
They call this audience attention.
What they do is they
measure the drop off rate
off of a YouTube video relative
to the average YouTube
video of that length.
Let's say the average
YouTube video at minute three
has lost 40% of its audience.
That's just a natural drop off rate.
At minute three, if I've
lost 40% of my audience,
I'll be hugging the line right there.
If I've only lost 20% of my
audience, I'll be above average.
That's what they're measuring
there, but you can imagine -
Actually, I've seen a few of my
videos where this curve does this.
It just drops off.
I can go at that exact
minute in the video and see,
Oh, I said orthogonality and
I never defined orthogonality.
I can either re-record the video,
I could put a little bubble there,
where you can get more information.
You're getting real data that
allows you to actually iterate
and perfect on what you're producing
and you can imagine two
dimensions, this is attention.
You could also have efficacy, if you
couple it with the actual exercise
and you keep iterating on it
until you have a gem of a video
and you can even have
multiple people's videos
and see what's better
for different people.
This all exists in Netflix.
There's no reason why it
shouldn't exist in education.
This right here is the big picture.
I'm talking about a virtual
school for the world.
This is what I think it's going
to be and I'm open to any ideas
or any nuance parts of it, but
you have your video library.
That's the low-hanging fruit, it's
the first line of instruction,
you can pause it and repeat it.
One thing, I spoke to a journal
of higher education recently
and sometimes I'm very diplomatic,
I don't rock too many boats,
but I was in a quirky mood and I hadn't
eaten for a long time. (laughter)
People who know my eating
habits, I often don't eat
for long periods of time,
but I just went off.
I was like, "I challenge you,"
because this is a journal
read by professors and educators.
I was like, "Why does a 300 person
lecture even exist anymore?"
In what way, just tell me
one way that that is better
than on-demand video.
I'm happy for any of you all to -
It's this broadcast
lecture to a room of people
in a certain amount of time
that's 90 minutes long,
people have gaps, and the
professor sees blank faces.
It's just this all around -
I think the only reason it exists
is because people associate it
with the college experience.
People expect when I pay 30
or $40,000, I should get this.
That's the only, in my
mind, why it exists.
With on-demand video you
can pause, repeat it.
The producer can get data on
what's working, what's not.
You can get your best professors
to produce the best content
and keep iterating it,
making it better and better.
People can fill in their gaps.
That's what the video library's all about.
Then you have the web applications.
You saw one of them, but
there's actually another one.
There's some gentlemen
in the back of the room
who started working on it.
There's a whole suite of web
applications you can build
for allowing people to
learn at their own pace.
What you saw was for math.
We're working on something.
I'd be happy to talk about
it if you're all curious
for more fact-based knowledge.
Learning american history or
geography, things like that.
You can even have web
applications for peer assessment,
for creative writing, all sorts of things.
When you actually compose things
for other people to review,
it becomes a whole other
level, whole other game
than when you're writing
something for a teacher to mark up
and say you're a B+
and then throw it away.
There's a whole suite of web
applications you can build
and then on top of that
you use all of that data
to actually facilitate
peer-to-peer interactions.
I hinted that in the classroom,
but there's no reason why
it just has to be
limited to the classroom.
If I'm having trouble
with quantum mechanics
and the best instructor for
quantum mechanics is in Mexico City
and we're both free at
4:00 PM eastern time,
no reason that we can't
set up an interaction
with a pen tablet, the way I used
to do it with my cousin Nadia
and have an interaction, even
better record that interaction,
so that other people in
the future can use it.
I rate them based on how they were,
they can even rate me on
how I was as a student
and the system knows what I did
before and after that interaction.
It actually knows whether it
was a statistically significant
intervention in some way.
This is the big picture and you
can just keep getting the data
and iterating and iterating and iterating
it to make it a better solution.
That's the master plan. (laughter)
Any questions?
Yeah.
Audience Member: I know
you've got this initial focus
of K through 12 and math and whatnot.
Audience Member: Sorry, we
can't hear the question.
Audience Member: Okay,
one of the things you said
really struck me as an
educator, which is your comment
about everyone should be
forced to be an A student.
If you think about this is
a (unintelligible) exercise
with a lot of unwilling institutions
trying to get them to change.
It seems to me that this
idea, just this one idea
would be very powerful to take
into professional certification,
say nursing degrees, where
you're not going to be a nurse
until you achieve this level
of competency on the exam.
Take a profession, where this idea
that everybody does
have to be an A student
in order to have a career and
get them to buy into this model
and maybe get the resources
from that sort of problem
or that sort of field
to test these ideas out
and to show how they work or they
find implementation or whatever.
Sal: I think it exists in
professional development,
because people say,
"Look, if you're a nurse
"and you don't know this,
people are going to die,"
so they do enforce that
with doctors, nurses, and -
That exists, but it isn't -
We could do studies, but I
think it's almost intuitive
that if you go back to -
Someone that has real mastery of algebra
is going to be way more
powerful than someone
who has B- student level of understanding
of algebra through differential equations.
They're never going to be
able to apply any of it,
as opposed to -
I've worked at - When I was
working at a hedge fund,
there was once a CFO who said -
I was like, "What's your
incremental gross margin?"
He's like, "Oh, we don't divulge that."
I was like, "You just gave it to me.
"You told me your gross
profit in two periods
"and how many units you sold
in two periods (laughter)
"That's your -
Everyone in the room was like, "Oh my God,
"this is some kind of
rocket science," (laughter)
That is algebra one, that is
algebra one, and no one in the room.
There are MBAs, there were PhDs
in the room, very smart people,
but no one could recognize
and that is a failure
and these are the successful
people in our education system.
People need to -
If we had real mastery of algebra,
the world would be a different place.
All the calculus and
all of that other stuff
would just be for fun, but it's not -
I don't even think it has to be tested.
If people really understood algebra,
that's going to be way better
than people halfway understanding algebra
and then moving on to other things.
Yeah?
Audience Member: A question about
the peer-to-peer interaction.
Do you see that happening now, actually?
If you have 16 million views on
YouTube, I imagine there's comments.
Is there comment moderation happening?
Sal: You all can go home and look.
Some of the debates or
even some of the commentary
on the YouTube videos
are like what teachers
would dream of having in their classroom.
Someone says, "Hey,
this was a great video,
"but I don't quite get what
Sal did at minute 2:34,"
and there's a little link in
YouTube you can go right back
to that little point in the video.
Then other people will
comment on it and say,
"Oh, you just have to
watch that other video
"and he explains that in depth," or,
"Here's another page you can watch,"
or they'll actually just
explain it right there.
This is just on a simple message board.
It definitely already exists
and it's literally just -
I get at least five emails a day
asking for a better community
to tap into this and I've just
been waiting to do it right.
It's there and people
love to help each other
and they just don't have a
good way of doing it right now.
Audience Member: I have children in
the first grade and fourth grade.
What would you suggest I
do with them with this?
Sal: First through fourth?
Audience Member: First and fourth.
Sal: This is not scientific.
I've tried out the app
with different aged kids.
The 1+1, it is 1+1 but it doesn't
have dancing bears. (laughter)
I hope to eventually have dancing -
Everyone likes dancing
(laughter) A Kindergartner.
I found Kindergarten -
I've seen some precocious second
or third graders get into it.
They don't need the
dancing bears and the music
and all of that type of thing.
Your fourth grader, I think,
could be ready for this.
The videos I've seen very
young kids like them.
They like the -
I don't know what they like about it.
They like the black
background and the colors.
They respond to the videos.
I've seen three or four year
olds, it holds their attention.
I don't know if they're
retaining anything. (laughter)
You might want to start with the
videos for your younger student,
but the fourth grader, I
think, is ready for the app.
Audience Member: The younger kid
goes straight to the YouTube.
Sal: Yeah, I think so, and you
might want to watch it with them.
Some people have told me that
they watch a couple of videos
at night with their kid and it's in
place of a bedtime story. (laughter)
Why not?
Audience Member: Are your
videos in your system
a little too big for one laptop per child?
Audience Member: What's the question?
Sal: The question is your
video and your system
a little too big for one laptop per child?
I guess there's a couple of -
In terms of ...
Audience Member: Getting
any of that content to them,
because right now I think they're
just doing textbook format, right?
Sal: Yeah, so the
question is, is it too big
for getting the content
into one laptop per child?
The easy answer is no.
When I first saw one laptop per child,
this is before Khan Academy
was really well thought out,
I was like, "What are they going to
do on that one laptop per child?"
There's examples of people
using it for lights and things
as opposed to for a computer.
I think it could be used
tomorrow on one laptop per child.
Audience Member: But do
they have enough drive space
and things like that?
A lot of them don't have
network connectivity.
Sal: The raw videos, they're
going to be on iTunes U soon,
so I just talked to the Apple
people and I handed them the disk
that had all the raw
videos and it was 40 gigs.
I think if you took the
Flash versions, it's 14 gigs.
I don't know how big the
hard drives are, though,
but soon they're going to be
able to store all of the -
Audience Member: It's actually
something you should look into,
because that's a big deal, right?
Sal: I would love to.
If they called me up, I'd
say, "Yeah." (laughter)
I'd love to, I'd love to.
We can have another talk about -
I'm talking to a couple of foundations.
One laptop per child would be
awesome if there's the resources,
but you don't necessarily
need one laptop per child.
Get some $200 refurbished
PC, put it in the village.
Now, all of a sudden, you can
have asynchronous learning,
which is what these village kids need,
because they have to
take off for the harvest,
they have a whole spectrum.
Some of them can't read, some of them have
pretty reasonable proficiency.
That $200 refurbished PC,
instead of being one per student,
you have 20 students
per day working on it,
each half an hour a day,
doing this type of thing,
and then as a foundation, for
the first time in the history
of philanthropic giving,
you actually have real data
on what's happening in real
time on the actual utilization
on your assets, where students
are, how they're performing
and in terms of the actual
cost, it's a $200 PC
that'll last four years,
so it's $50 a year
and you're educating 20 students.
That's $2.50 per student
per year for an education,
which is competitive with
anywhere in the third world.
It's cheaper than pencil and paper.
I think that's what should be the model,
but if they get a laptop
that's even better.
Oh, in the back, yeah.
Audience Member: I think you said you do
all the video and lectures yourself.
How long does it take you
to put together a module?
There's some topic areas surely you
don't know all of it. (laughter)
Sal: A video, if it's a work -
There's probably people emailing
me right now some algebra.
I think I may really be doing
some kid's homework for them.
Those type of things where
it's just an algebra problem,
someone emails it to me, I haven't
done that exact problem before,
let me just do it, that's
the ten minutes on the video,
plus five minutes to upload,
it's a very small amount of time.
If you saw that first screen, I've
started doing world history videos.
Those take a lot of -
Audience Member: What
do you mean by a lot?
Sal: When I started on
the French Revolution,
I spent a week doing nothing but
reading on the French Revolution.
I literally just took time off and I
steeped myself in the French Revolution.
I think we've all found this
when we were going to school
is that when you're in
the midst of a class,
you really are an expert for
that short period of time
until the exam you are an expert,
but then it all goes away. (laughter)
For that short period
of time, you can talk
to any academic anywhere in the world
and you know all of the details
and the nuances and everything.
About a week of studying
and it's fun studying.
It's not for an exam, it's for me
and I get to make YouTube videos.
I'll do that and then I'll
start making the videos
and then I can probably produce
two or three videos a day.
Once I have the big picture and
I understand the major pieces
and I have a sense of -
If you watch those videos, I
cut and paste a bunch of images
and maps from Wikipedia
and I just explain them.
I'm a big map person, so I do that.
In the back?
Audience Member: Is the software
that you use to do things
like draw perfectly straight
lines or doing a ratio
something you can buy off
the shelf (unintelligible)
or did you design that all yourself?
Sal: No, some people have
offered to pay for it,
but I didn't build any software.
Actually, all I use is I started
off using Microsoft Paint.
I made the background
black and I used this thing
called Screen Video Recorder,
too, which is this shareware,
freeware, or $20 screen capture software.
That's what I started the first
500 videos were done like that.
Then someone just sent
me a Camtasia license.
They're like, "This is great,
we need to (unintelligible).
"You need a better screen capture."
So I started using Camtasia and
then I used Smooth Draw, too,
which is pressure sensitive,
so it actually looks like
I'm writing with a pen,
as opposed to Microsoft Paint,
but you could get set up
for $200 at home with exactly what I have.
It's all found stuff.
There's probably better stuff out there.
What I'm using right now, I
can't draw a straight line.
With Microsoft Paint I could,
because it had the line tool.
Audience Member: In line with your
idea of this as entertainment,
so replacing bedtime stories, I
think there's a niche for retirees.
I know any number of people
who, first thing in the morning,
do three crosswords and a sudoku.
Sal: Exactly.
Audience Member: (unintelligible)
Sal: (unintelligible)
My mother in law
(unintelligible) (laughter)
I have gotten letters from retirees saying
that they started doing
it instead of sudoku
and other than keeping them sharp,
they're not connecting
with their grandkids.
They're becoming the grandkids' tutor
and this is a whole level of connection
that they couldn't have
before, so there is something.
Not the retirees, there's a
lot of homeschooling parents -
I think there's a lot of
homeschoolers who are doing great
until about algebra and then
they're like, "What do I do next?"
This is helping them out.
There's a lot of people who surprise me.
There's a lot of military
people who are actually my age
who are going back to college.
If you think about it,
if you're in your mid-30s
and you want to go back to college,
and the first thing you're going
to see when you go to college
is college algebra and (unintelligible)
There is nothing out there for you.
You're helpless and this is
the only thing that's out there
and they're eternally thankful
that they could re-learn
arithmetic and algebra
and all these things
that they haven't seen for 20 years.
It's surprising.
Audience Member: I have an eighth grader
and my question is, would you
say that the videos sometimes
could replace going back to the
textbook when they get stuck, or -
Sal: Yeah, so the question and this -
Audience Member: Because the textbooks -
Sal: Oh, don't get me started
about textbooks. (laughter)
No, I will get started about textbooks.
The question was, "I
have an eighth grader.
"Do you think the videos
can replace the textbook?"
Let's think about what a textbook is.
There's two things in a textbook.
There's something that claims
to be some form of explanation,
two pages of text on something,
and then it's exercises.
There's 50 problems (unintelligible).
I guarantee you on-demand
video, whether it's Khan Academy
or anybody, is going to
be better than that prose
or whatever you want to call it,
that's trying to explain the concept
and it's usually explained
more for peer-review,
more for the other
textbook authors saying,
"Oh yes, he did it
rigorously, that's excellent,"
as opposed for the
eighth grader who wants -
Audience Member: (unintelligible)
Sal: Exactly, I think there's
a small subset of people
who could actually read a textbook
and that's what a lot of us
would probably get where
we got, because we could
actually consume that
information, but most people -
On-demand video is better than that
and from an exercise point of view,
the textbook company doesn't know
who's doing what exercise when,
who's watching what, what's
actually being effective.
They're not getting real-time data.
That stuff I showed -
You can argue what the
modules should look like,
but something like that is
going to be infinitely better,
especially if you can tweak it
and get data on what's working,
what are people using.
For all we know, textbook publishers,
half of those problems are
never touched by anybody.
They're in there and
kids are getting hernias
carrying those problems
around and it's a -
The answer's yes, I think that textbooks
need to go, on a lot of levels.
Audience Member: So for world history,
what kind of problems do you put out there
so you can make your assessment?
Sal: The question is for world history
what kind of problems
can you put out there?
What I showed you, those modules,
that's good for something
that can be templatized, that you can map.
You can even do some physics problems
like that, the core problems.
You could do some types of
chemistry, maybe genetics,
but what about the
causes of the Civil War.
Audience Member: Not just that,
but analysis of complex issues.
Sal: Yeah, there's two levels
of things like history.
One is the, "What did
Millard Fillmore do?"
There's that level and
then there's the level of,
"Let's talk about the impacts
of slavery today," or something.
The core stuff, and
that's what I'm working on
with those two gentlemen
in the back there.
Literally I met them,
(unintelligible) we met last week,
but what we're working on is a -
We're working on -
If we were studying for
a factual based thing,
we would get together in a big study group
and write flash cards for each
other and then quiz each other
on each other's questions.
What we're working on is a world -
For American History, put
the whole curriculum there
and then if you say, "I'm
going to write a question
"on the Antebellum Period."
Click Antebellum, you write a question,
you can embed a video,
image, whatever you want.
Once you feel good about it,
you put the correct choice,
incorrect choices, explanation.
Once you feel good about
it, you publish it.
If I'm the first person
to see your question,
I'll say, "Hey, warning, this
is an untouched question,"
and all of that stuff,
but you should try it out.
I do the question, I rate it on
quality, difficulty, and importance
and then you start building
this library of questions
with metadata around
it and you can imagine
that you're collecting data,
people who knew this question
didn't know that question,
so you can quantitatively say
what's easy or what's harder.
There's all sorts of ways
you can consume the question.
You could imagine a teacher, because
you're getting all of this data.
You know exactly how long it takes
for a certain type of student
to complete a question, whether
they get it right or wrong.
You can imagine a history teacher,
once you get this huge data,
this huge library questions,
like you know what,
I want to administer an exam to
my history students tomorrow,
I'm going to bring them
to the computer lab.
I want 50 questions and I don't
want more than a 95% chance
that more than two people
aren't going to finish that exam
and we'll have all of the
data, because it'll know
for that level of student
how long it'll take them,
it'll do the statistical model
and then, bam, (unintelligible).
That's for the core and you
can do that for anything.
(unintelligible)
The more nuanced stuff,
that's an open question.
I'm open to ideas.
I think there's things,
a peer review of essays,
or you could argue through
essays and have people vote
on who's argument is better.
There's all sorts of things you can do.
That hasn't been -
Foreign language, I was
thinking, I have a 15 month old.
Skype exists, the best foreign language,
I'm going to have him chat
for a half an hour a week
with somebody in Mexico
City, Dubai, Hong Kong.
Half an hour a week and he'll just chat.
That's foreign language.
I think there's some very simple things
with found technology right now that
that could solve some of these problems.
The immersion, as opposed
to (unintelligible).
Oh, yeah?
Audience Member: Very
curious to hear your thoughts
about the Texas Board of Education and -
Sal: What about education?
Audience Member: Have you heard
about the Texas Board of Education?
Sal: Oh, the Texas Board
of Education (crosstalk)
Audience Members: They're
trying to rewrite the textbooks,
especially around American history.
I'm wondering if that made
you rethink about your mission
with Khan Academy or -
Sal: Oh yeah, that's interesting.
He's asking about the
Texas Board of Education,
the rewriting of American
History and all that.
From a personal level, that's
the power of this thing.
I could all of a sudden -
I do every now and then
go on Google blog search
and I see who's using
these Khan Academy videos.
Obviously, it's a lot of
homeschoolers and all that,
but actually, a White Supremacy group
loves the Khan Academy. (laughter)
Because they're like, "This
is quality instruction,
"our kids aren't getting
it, this is the only way
"that they're going to be able
to compete with the Asians
"and the Jews and the - (laughter)
They could've gotten me to teach them,
or they would've let me get into
their house and teach their kid,
but because they recognize
that this is better
than what they're getting in the school,
I'm able to get into those
kids' heads, (laughter)
which would never
(unintelligible) (laughter)
I think that whole Texas thing,
I think it's a non-issue.
I think with the internet
and all that, they can debate
night and day over what
should be in the textbook,
no one's going to care
at the end of the day,
because they're going to get
information from other sources.
The reality is most of
the kids aren't learning
what they're trying to put in the
textbooks, so who cares? (laughter)
Audience Member: Are you able to -
Different people learn in different ways.
For example, some people
might learn with examples
and other people want to
learn more deductively.
Can you identify the
ways that people learn
and then adjust the instruction
to match the special need?
Sal: Yeah, the question was can
you adjust to deductive learners
versus people who need examples?
We could.
I don't do it yet, I don't claim
that it's already done and all that,
but it definitely could be done
and that's another value of this.
Some people say, "Oh, are you
teaching it this new way or regrouping
"or are you teaching the
old way with borrowing
abstract manipulative way
"or are you teaching ...
Let's do both, let's do both,
and people can pick and choose
what they want or do both.
In a traditional classroom, you
have to make these decisions
because you have a scarce amount of time,
scarce amount of resources, you have
to teach it this way or that way,
but here you can teach them both ways.
Teach it the deductive way
and then do a lot of examples,
because that's the way
most people enjoy it.
There's nothing to stop you from doing it.
Audience Member: I saw the graph earlier,
where you show how you
get from (unintelligible)
all the way through and that's
how the (unintelligible) works
to build a foundation and you
can extend that even further
by anything that's factual,
history or geography,
by taking the graph (unintelligible).
You can imagine, after you just
learned about the French Revolution,
and a lesson about French geography,
you could then be
offered to take a look at
(unintelligible) for example
and since you've learned
about (unintelligible) you can
learn about (unintelligible)
can get you to (unintelligible)
you can always relate it
to something you already know.
Sal: Especially once you
have a question library
and you think about the
best way to navigate it.
Right now it's just a curriculum.
You can say, "I want to learn
about the French Revolution,"
but (unintelligible) organically,
what you're suggesting.
I haven't built it, but
it can be built today,
and it's kind of silly
that it's not being built,
especially considering how
leverage-able something like that is.
Audience Member: Have you
thought about teaching parents,
educators, teachers on how to teach,
how to communicate
effectively to your audience,
how to troubleshoot where
the hangups, the gaps are.
Sal: The questions is have I
ever thought about teaching
to educators or parents how to -
There's an interesting story there, too.
This was when Khan Academy was like,
I was happy if anyone
called me (unintelligible)
Three years ago, Miami
Dade contacted me and said,
"Can we use your videos
for teacher training?"
I was like, "Yeah, sure, that's awesome."
You all are real educators and
you all want to use my videos.
I was like, "but why don't you let the
students use them, too." (laughter)
There is a reality now where ...
I think there would be
value in telling teachers,
"Look, you don't have to
be perfect, just be human,
"and just be conversational,
and don't talk down,
"and don't try to use this
as a power exertion type
"of classroom management
type of thing, use it -
I don't blame teachers,
because the system forces them
to manage a classroom, demand respect,
if they have a gap in their
knowledge, you can't be honest.
If you do that in a classroom then
they're going to undermine you.
There's all these other
dynamics that occur
why a teacher can't be human.
We're in a world where we'll
probably get a subset of teachers
who are scaling up and then the
rest of the teachers leverage this
to become the human one-on-one mentor
and I think that'll be the value.
It'll just be kind of example if they say,
"Hey, let's watch this together,"
and then, "Did you get it?
"If you don't then I'll be your
mentor to walk you through it."
I'd be happy to if anyone
was interested in me doing
(unintelligible) anything
like that, but yeah.
Audience Member: I'm curious about
the peer-to-peer interactions
and community and how you've got
and where you could be going.
You've touched on a couple of things
I think are just world-changing.
Intergenerational,
knowledge transfer, wisdom,
you talked about one room schoolrooms,
but what about just
the usual parent-child.
There's so much that could
happen using this model.
Where are you?
Sal: Yeah, so the peer-to-peer,
that's at the most on the
drawing board right now.
I haven't ... I've tried it out
with my cousins as a one off basis.
I feel like it'll definitely work
and the data is being set off,
but knock on whatever this
is made out of. (laughter)
Hopefully in the next few weeks
we'll get some resources to start doing -
That's the most technically intensive
and we want to get to the point
where not only are we doing peer-to-peer
and it's seamless and it's capturing data,
but it's also recording
those interactions.
You need some -
Once you record, then
it's (unintelligible).
I agree with the whole teacher, with the -
I want a world where you can -
If your parents want
to take you to Europe,
it's not going to
compete with your school.
You go on that trip to Europe
and maybe there's another
one room schoolhouse
part of the same network
that you can go to
and meet the kids in
Paris while you're there.
On the plane you can do -
(unintelligible) I agree
with you completely.
The peer-to-peer is the hardest to do
and it's going to be the
one that maybe happens,
but I think it'll happen
in the next five years.
I think the potential is large.
Audience Member: What's
the optimal length or range
for the different modules
and how many times
do you have to retape it to satisfy
yourself that it's good enough?
Sal: The question is,
what's the optimal length
for I'm assuming the videos especially
and how many times do I have to retape it?
When I started off, YouTube
limits you to 10 minutes.
Now they let me do longer videos,
I'm a partner and all of that,
but when you start off it's 10 minutes,
so my first video was 11 minutes and
they didn't let me upload it. (laughter)
I paid attention to the
clock and I made my videos
around nine or ten minutes.
That's the single
biggest point of feedback
that that is the ideal amount of
time to get one concept across
while being able to pay attention.
I've gotten letters from people.
I've talked to some people
at Google who have done
some user interface
stuff and how long people
can pay attention and they said,
"Yeah, it's about ten minutes."
I think that might even
be what motivated YouTube
to figure out the limit, but
that forced me to do that.
One, that's a granular chunk that
allows people to pay attention.
It turns it into one of these
DaVinci Code Dan Brown type novels
where each chapter's three
pages and you're like,
"Okay, I'm done," and you
get a sense of completion,
as opposed to a 90 minute lecture
that you can only watch
40 minutes and you feel -
This also makes it very granular.
You can really just jump in
and get exactly what you need
as opposed to sitting
through a 90 minute lecture
and trying to find -
I've found that ten minutes
is now I'm getting to -
Actually, I've done a few videos
now that are pushing 20 minutes,
but that's just my fault.
I really think everything
can be done in ten minutes.
Your other thing is how
many times do I do it?
Audience Member: Do you have to
tape and retape several times
to get it to where you want it (crosstalk)
Sal: Oh quality?
Audience Member: Yeah.
Sal: How many times do I have to -
When I started, since
it was for my cousins,
I literally would record
it and put up. (laughter)
There's actually one or two videos
where I'm answering telemarketer calls.
(laughter) I didn't care.
Why re-record it?
It's for Nadia.
This is free (unintelligible).
That's another takeaway.
People like that
informality, they like that -
I make mistakes.
I would say one out of every
12 videos I make on arithmetic,
I forget a negative number
or I forget a negative sign
or I say 16-8 is 5.
I do something bizarre and people
really like that. (laughter)
Or I start a problem and go
around the wrong path first
and I say, "Oh wait, that's not right."
I've gotten positive feedback on
those things because you never see it.
When you go to a class, the
teacher they have the script,
they've done that problem 20
times and they just do it perfect.
You're an idiot if you didn't
see this, obvious steps,
but when you see someone who
kind of knows what they're doing,
they follow their intuition in
one direction, it was wrong,
that's okay, that's the art of
mathematics, of solving a problem.
Then you go down a complete other path.
I try now that it's
getting more notoriety,
I feel like, "Oh my God, so many
people are going to watch this video,
"let me re-do it," but I find
the more I think that way
it hurts the quality of the video.
Audience Member: Does Kaplan or any
of the other paid for online
services, Phoenix University,
do any of them view you as a
competitive threat, being free?
Sal: They should. (laughter)
I've actually spoke to the
research group at Apollo Group,
which is the parent company
for the University of Phoenix.
I think they're aware of it now.
I've talked to Princeton
Review about potentially -
Because I would like to do something
with their materials and all of that.
In any of these groups,
even textbook publishers,
I've talked to a few, there's a group
that's very insecure about everything,
but there's another view that's
like, "Look, this is out there
"and this could even
empower your instruction."
If I do all the SAT
problems out of your book,
hopefully you'll donate
to me and I can do them,
that's not going to
prevent people from taking
your Princeton Review course.
It's going to make your time
in your Princeton Review course
way more productive, because the
kids will have done the problems,
get all their questions
answered by this Sal guy
and then they can have
this one-on-one interaction
with the guy you're paying to teach.
I've talked to Princeton
Review and the Apollo Group
who definitely believe that, but
then they have to fight the inertia
of we have this billion dollar
franchise, we can't mess it up.
Once they really view me as a competitor,
then I'll start getting
security. (laughter)
Audience Member: Hi, I'm
wondering if you can speak
on anything more to how you devised
the content for your videos.
Are you looking at textbooks
and here's the order of content,
because you're not a fan of textbooks.
I'm wondering if there's a
potential to reconceptualize
the way knowledge is
organized to begin with,
because I was lucky, I could
follow textbooks very well,
but our natural curiosities
don't follow (unintelligible).
Early childhood educators are
very often going to have that.
You go to class
(unintelligible) and it's killed
many children's natural curiosities.
How can you link the
basics that you're teaching
to the real world questions that we have?
(unintelligible)
Sal: The question is how
do I build the curriculum?
How do I decide what to cover,
given that I'm not a fan -
I'm not a fan of a textbook
as a primary learning source
for someone who's -
I do look at textbooks.
I don't go straight, section 12-1, next
lecture, section 12-2, next lecture.
Actually, there's a textbook publisher
who wanted me to do videos for their book
and they said, "I want you to do
exactly this concept on this video."
I looked at that concept, I was like,
"There's no way I can get myself
- It would be so boring.
It would be just so mundane it
would just kill all my credibility
if I were to do a video on that.
My thing is I try to get the big picture
(unintelligible) with
the French Revolution.
Spend some time, mull over it, and
then once you have the big picture,
then try to take the nuggets that
will build you the big picture.
Then maybe use the
textbook or something else
just to make sure you're comprehenseive.
The kid's going to see
everything that they might face
when they take an assessment.
I use a ton of Wikipedia, I use textbooks,
I use other open
courseware sometimes, to -
A lot of stuff is hard to consume.
You really have to be motivated to consume
or already even have a foundation
to consume a lot of these things.
I feel my value-added
is taking all of that
and distilling it down
to something useful.
Audience Member: In your model up there
you have a figure (unintelligible)
How have you thought of looking
at environmental (unintelligible)
Stress can be measured in
learning by somebody blinking or -
(unintelligible)
Sal: The question is right
now I'm just tracking
when they're doing the problem,
how long it's taking them,
what time of day they're doing it,
did they get it right or wrong,
did they click the hint,
all that type of stuff,
but there's this whole what
was their blood pressure
while they were doing
the problem, (laughter)
where did their eyes move,
what is their cycles in
their brain doing on an EEG?
I think that'd be awesome.
You could do some biofeedback stuff.
That's a whole frontier that I think is -
Audience Member: The only
bad thing is you don't want
to hook somebody up to
an EEG (unintelligible)
Sal: (unintelligible) If it can be
done, try it out and see if it -
I think that'd be awesome.
Camerawoman: There's research
already in effective computing
in Media Lab and Rosalind Picard.
That's what (crosstalk)
She was my adviser.
Then they do sweat measurement
and eye dilation (crosstalk)
Sal: I think the fun thing about
this, what I view as the Khan Academy,
right now it's very content focused.
Everything I talked about was the videos
and these modules and all of
that, but where I see it going
is the content is really just seeding.
In order to do all this data
stuff, you need the content,
but once you have a critical mass of
content, then the data takes over.
You can start doing some
really fascinating things
with experiments that you
couldn't have done before
and real-time learning and biofeedback
and all this other (unintelligible)
I think that'd be awesome.
Audience Member: In the
beginning of your talk
you said your visitors to your
website surpass MIT (unintelligible)
Is that true?
Sal: I'll give you all my data.
Audience Member: (unintelligible)
Sal: How do I know that
it's past (unintelligible)
Audience Member: (unintelligible)
Sal: There's a couple things.
There's an interesting thing about -
Just on YouTube, which I think
is the primary consumption area
for most open courseware,
it has passed up MIT.
You can actually look at the cumulative
upload views on a daily basis
and just measure the delta and you can see
that Khan Academy's
getting about 60 or 70,000,
MIT's getting about 30 to 40,000.
I think next up is Berkeley's getting
15,000 or something like that.
That's just on that.
I don't have access to
MIT's actual weblogs.
(unintelligible) Definitely on
the internet, I'm not 100% sure.
Audience Member: It's
definitely a different audience.
Sal: That's the other interesting thing.
There's all this open courseware,
people spend millions of
dollars putting cameras in,
but Khan Academy's really only
the game in town for K through 12,
which is where all the need is.
It's not like I'm like, "Oh, MIT ...
They're catering to us.
If we took 1806 already and we
just want to review something,
we can consume that, but
that's not for a ninth grader
who wants to learn how to learn a matrix.
For K through 12, I
think that's one reason
why Khan Academy has picked up,
because it is directly
addressing its audience.
I think, on top of that, the
open courseware movement,
which I think is awesome,
but their first time
it let's put videos in classrooms.
They didn't rethink the form factor.
They didn't say, "Well, is this
really the best way to learn online?"
We're just saying, "We're
going to show you what goes on
in an MIT classroom,"
which I think is awesome.
Audience Member: When it first
came out, it was revolutionary.
Sal: No, it was.
That was my proudest day as an alum.
Audience Member: What I
found is that it seemed to be
dumping all this information.
Sal: Yeah, there's two things
that it's going when you go there.
One is it's hard to navigate.
You don't know what to watch next,
so it's not for someone
who's never seen it before.
There's no direct path
and the other thing is
even when I was making videos I was
doing the (unintelligible) video.
This whole time I was like
(unintelligible) MIT stuff.
I went to the thermodynamics lectures
and I had to sift through
so much non-entropy talk
to finally get to entropy
and then finally there was
an exactly what I want, so
it's very hard to consume.
Even when you watch the video, I'm not -
I think it was an awesome thing,
especially because in 2000 or 2001,
every other university was doing some type
of for profit, University
of Phoenix-ish type of thing
and MIT, it's going to be free.
I think it's awesome, but
if you watch the videos,
I probably watched, I think
more than any of you all,
I watched more open courseware videos.
Every now and then, the
professor puts up a slide
that's like, "This is a copyright
issue, you cannot see what this -
I'm like, "Oh my God, how am I
going to understand?" (laughter)
It happens one out of every five videos.
Or the camera is just
not where it should be.
You can't see -
I think it's awesome for
other universities to see
what MIT is doing and it
takes a lot of security
on the part of MIT to do that -
Audience Member: It takes some
confidence to release (crosstalk)
Everything you have, basically.
Sal: Because it says there's
a value of being here
and also it's, "Look,
this leaves us open,"
because before this, everyone would think
all these secret things are
happening at MIT that are special,
but now you know exactly what's happening
and it loses the (unintelligible)
mystique of (unintelligible)
I agree, but I talked to open courseware
and I'm open to talking to
them as much as possible.
I asked them, "Hey, how
about Khan Academy becomes
"your K through 12 offering?
"Because this will help recruit
kids, get them interested,
"I'm an alum and we could get other -
They were putting video cameras
in the classrooms right now,
but hopefully that changes.
I think I would love to
recruit other professors
to do this form factor,
get other students,
get you all to do whatever
you all want to do.
Audience Member:
(unintelligible) (laughter)
Sal: The questions is how much
of the success of the site
related to the incompetency of teachers?
This is a sensitive subject. (laughter)
Audience Member: (unintelligible)
Sal: How many teachers
are in the - (laughter)
The reality is there
are incompetent anybody,
there are incompetent x, and
unfortunately, some kids,
that's all they get and I
think there's a lot of that.
Just look at the -
The only comments I delete from the site
are when there's profane
language and even those,
some I don't get to.
These are unedited
comments and you'll see,
on pretty much every video,
at least half the comments
are some kid who's angry that
they're paying x thousand dollars
in tuition to whatever and
they spent a whole semester
trying to learn it and they
thought it was impossible to learn,
they spent ten minutes on some
video and that's all it was
and they're angry, they genuinely
want to kill somebody. (laughter)
I think that's out there.
A professor in Montreal
wrote a blog post about this.
It's just like even if you say
this above average instruction.
We can debate is it better than
90%, is it better than 50%,
but even if it's above
average instruction,
even if this instruction
better than 50% of instructors,
what's the point of having
those 50% of instructors.
It's a thought experiment
that should happen.
Even if I'm not the 95th
% instructor, someone is.
Then you get that person,
or someone's the 99th
percentile instructor
and if you have that person,
then why are you having
the other 99 out of 100 delivering
lectures, but there is -
It goes into a lot of teachers
are a product of the same system.
They're products of where
they don't have the intuitions
and the connections and because
of that, they're passing on
this rote, superficial understanding
of things for generations.
Audience Member: (unintelligible)
Sal: The question, I think,
is is it just going to be me
or are there other potential people?
Even the top notch thing, it's
not clear that MIT instruction
is better than what you're
going to get at the local high -
Those guys are going to be kick butt,
in terms of the research
they're doing and all of that,
but instruction that might
be ideal for an MIT student,
some of the MIT lectures,
I think they're confident
because they say, "Look how
hard this class is." (laughter)
The question about other instructors,
when I started this, I assumed
that was going to be the case.
I assumed that I had done
30 videos and I was like,
"Oh, this is fun and
people are watching it.
"Let me get my other buddies from
MIT and they'll make some videos
"and I'll see if they're interested."
Some were interested,
but it was harder for me
to get people to do videos than
for me to just do them myself.
After some point, I had
maybe 100 or 200 videos
and I said, "This is algebra,
it's pretty much done."
I said, "I'm just going to keep
going," but I'm open to it.
If someone wants to -
A couple people have volunteered, I said,
"Make 50 videos.
"If I think those 50 videos
are of the same stock -
Even if they don't get
associated with Khan Academy,
they're going to have value by themselves.
They're going to be on YouTube,
the world can access them.
If I think they're of the same
style and they're coherent
with this brand, I'll
push traffic that way,
especially there's a guy who
just contacted me about music.
He wants to do a music video.
I don't know anything about
music (unintelligible)
until you teach me about music.
I'm open to it, but I don't
think it's something I could put
a job posting for (unintelligible)
The other thing is a lot
of very good instructors
freeze up a little bit
in this form factor,
because you are putting
yourself out there.
If you're a Nobel Prize
PhD, it's a lot harder
when someone criticizes you than me.
I'm just a guy, but when
you're the authority,
to put yourself out there in that way,
sometimes a little daunting to -
Audience Member: I don't
know if this is for you
or your crack programming team,
but how far away are you from
having forget the videos,
at least the drilling module
for high school algebra one
on a DS or an iPod Touch?
Sal: How far is the module from a -
Audience Member: Having
a complete drill set,
all the questions, all the metrics,
everything being able to load.
Put junior in the back of the
minivan and do two problems
every 15 minutes or every five minutes
and teach junior algebra one
in the back of the minivan,
all year, not having to go to class.
Sal: Oh yeah, iPad
(unintelligible) iPad expert.
I think it's literally -
We don't have but one developer
for six months devoted on that
would probably be able to migrate -
Audience Member: Would
the data fit, though?
How much data would you need for that?
Sal: I think it's just a matter of
syncing it and that type of thing,
it'd just be implementation,
but I think it could easily
be consumed and done, especially
on an iPad or something like that.
There's no reason why
that shouldn't be done.
Audience Member: You're non-profit, right?
Sal: Yes.
Audience Member: Do
you see yourself moving
to a revenue model and
have another approach?
Sal: Yeah, I'm surprised it
took this long (laughter)
(unintelligible)
It's a not for profit, 51C3,
and it was interesting,
because about a year ago,
before I quit my job,
I wanted to quit my job.
It was a good job, but
I wanted to do this,
and some PCs had contacted me saying,
"Hey, we love what you're doing
"and we think you're
doing education right.
"How about we do a hybrid model?
"You're going to get a
salary and you can do this.
" We'll have some premium
content or this or that,"
and I was very close to doing that,
but then the more and
more I thought about it,
especially when I spoke to
them, I knew that at some point
our desires were going to
conflict and my worst nightmare
is that all these videos I
did, all of this gets acquired
by McGraw-Hill (laughter)
and it gets thrown
in some library someplace and
just disappears from the planet.
For me, the real joy of this,
even if I'm forced to drive
a used Honda my entire life, is
that my great-great-grandkids
might be able to learn
calculus from these videos.
That, to me, is the most
tremendously exciting powerful thing.
It is not for profit, it was being funded
by my bank account until very recently.
Actually, last week, Ann and John Doerr
wrote a $100,000 check
to give me a salary,
so you don't have to do too much.
I'll take some sandwiches, but I'm okay.
I'm talking to some fairly
large corporations now
that they're like, "Yeah, this -
I tell them, "Show me a higher
social return on an investment."
Get half a million dollar budget,
we'll have three, four developers,
we can educate millions
of kids for all time.
It's not like this is a charter school
and as soon as the money
disappears the school disappears.
As long as someone's paying $50 a month
for the web hosting (laughter)
it's going to exist forever.
Now it's being replicated on this, it's
getting on all sorts of hard drives
and we're going to put it on
BitTorrent and all of that,
so we don't even have to
pay for the web hosting.
You're building a library that can
continue to deliver social returns.
You do any type of (unintelligible)
it's like $500,000 per year investment,
the social return is going to be,
especially if you translate it
into five languages, it's
like $5 billion a year,
if you associate a video view with $1.
It's ridiculous and I hope
people are seeing that.
Hopefully we'll get some.
Audience Member: (unintelligible)
Sal: I am not going to
sell out. (laughter)
There might be a movie one day. (laughter)
Hopefully I won't sell out.
Audience Member: To follow
on that a little bit,
you told us a number
of ways that education
is entrenched in productive ways.
Is this interesting in a
way Wikipedia's interesting
or is it interesting
in ways that can end up
transforming education as it exists today?
This would be good supplemental
material (unintelligible) (crosstalk)
Sal: I'll repeat it.
The question is do I envision
this as being what Wikipedia is,
which is a tremendous
impact, but a supplemental,
nice to have for the
world, or is this something
that could transform education?
I think in the short term it's the former,
but in the long term, and for
me long term is ten years,
I think it really is -
A big part of this, I view
this as the operating system
with the DNA for a physical school
and I actually do a little summer
camp, really for me to experiment
with what you do with the
rest of the school day,
because I can do this for
two hours and then it frees
the rest of the time for creative things,
to actually write computer programs,
compose music, paint, to
actually build things.
My goal is that summer
camp's going to get longer
and longer and longer. (laughter)
Actually, the San Jose Tech Museum
is going to give us some space.
We're going to start
having a presence there.
That physical experiment's going
to get more and more substantial
and at some point, we're going to be like,
"We're a real school now
and this is the prototype,"
and I don't want to do it if it's
only 5% better outcomes than what -
I want kids, "Hey, I just
painted that picture,
"I just built that robot,
and by the way I'm 12
"and I'm learning calculus."
I want to see that and I think
once you have one example of that,
but I think (unintelligible)
Then I think you set the example
and I think the rest of the
world's going to be like,
"Wait, even our $40,000 a year fancy
private school is not doing that
"and they're charging $5,000
a student," as opposed to -
Audience Member: Then the
next question that comes,
if you do that, this seems to
apply to self-selecting students
who seek out the materials and
even in the case of the camp,
obviously there's some selection there.
How applicable are the ideas then of
going through school (unintelligible)
Sal: Right, the idea is
this is right now applicable
to a self-selecting pool of students
and even the summer camp
I'm doing and that's true
and how do you apply it to a broader -
I think there's two -
The summer camp that I
showed the data with,
the selection criteria was
not kids with a certain IQ
or kids who've done -
That was just non-problem kids.
This was mainly minority
kids from east Palo Alto,
Redwood City, Menlo Park, who they
didn't have discipline problems,
but I think that could describe 80%
of students, probably 90% of students.
I'd say problem the subset
that have discipline problems,
a lot of it is because they're
not being addressed in this way
that they have these gaps
and no one can address it
and there's all sorts of social stigmas.
It's ridiculous that concepts
and age are associated
in this tightly linked way that
if you're 13 and you need help
with decimals you're stupid and
I'm going to make fun of you.
I think that leads to a lot of
social acting out and all that.
Actually, I want to get this into prisons,
because they have a
lot of time. (laughter)
I don't know the exact answer,
there would be some experimentation,
but I suspect that this is going to appeal
to a larger swath
because it's interactive.
Everything about it, you're
never having to sit passively.
You're learning the way people
naturally want to learn.
I think a lot of these
hyperactive kids or whatever,
they're natural learners, they
just don't like being lectured to.
They like to be interactive and
talk to their peers and whatnot.
We'll see where that goes,
but it's an interesting seed.
It's an interesting question.
If there is something that can really
accelerate 90% of the students,
but it leaves behind 10%, is
that a good or a bad thing
and that's a whole social
debate that one could have.
Audience Member: In case there
is a movie made about you,
can the other Salman Khan
play this Salman Khan.
Sal: Oh yeah, he says,
"Can the other Salman -
For those who've never done
a web search for Salman Khan,
I encourage you to do so when you go home,
because there's an Indian
actor with my name.
I think that's helped me beat MIT
open courseware, as well. (laughter)
Audience Member: One issue
you might have thought about,
I've watched a second
grader in the neighborhood
who is homeschooled and I'm
afraid he's really missing out
on the socialization factor.
If we transition more to
this method of teaching,
how would we not lose that?
Sal: Right, so the question's
on socialization factor.
I want to be very clear,
this is on the internet,
essentially and someone could
be sitting in an isolated room
and doing this and not
having any socialization,
but the goal when I described
the one room schoolhouse
is that it actually is social.
For the first time, you actually
do get socialization in a school.
Most of us, there's a thousand
kids in the schoolhouse,
but you don't get any interaction,
especially in a meaty way,
except in recess and lunch, but
now this is actually encouraging
socialization in the classroom,
where you're tutoring each other.
That's actually very good socialization.
If you think about when do you want
to give someone a big thumbs up?
Right now, the system
says, "Oh, you're a genius,
"you got an 800 on your SAT."
That's where you get the thumbs up,
but the real thumbs up
is you're a good teacher,
you have empathy, you have maturity.
When other kids respect you
for your ability to communicate
and not talk down to them.
If you think about what
people will get points for,
I want it to be that, that
the data and assessments show
that you're a great teacher to your peers.
If you're an employer or a
university, those are the kids
you want to admit, not the
kid who's just racing ahead
and just arrogant and all of that.
I think it will actually help
socialization, especially
the one room model.
Oh, yeah.
Audience Member: When
are you speaking at TED?
Sal: Oh, the question is when
am I speaking at TED? (laughter)
I don't know.
Actually, I just had a - I don't know.
If they call me I'll go. (laughter)
I'll be speaking at Pop -
Have you all heard of PopTech.
It's this thing in New Hampshire.
It's like a mini-TED. (laughter)
Audience Member: Would you
speak at TEDx, if they call you?
Sal: I'll be good anywhere.
I speak at the old
(unintelligible) (laughter)
Excellent, thank you. (applause)